all right so this is this is one of
those videos where
i've been pacing trying to get my
thoughts in order for this one and i
feel like i'm
gonna pace for three more hours and
still not have my thoughts ready to do
this video
lord of the flies is one of those
stories that
shines a spotlight on human nature so
i'm here talking about
what i see and what it means to me and
you know i just want to get it right so
i'm i feel like i'm going to be at best
for the most part right so hopefully
that's enough
anyhow i want to talk about lord of the
flies no idea why i call it inspiration
[Music]
lord of the flies so lord of the flies
is actually two films it was a book
written by william golding and then it
was adapted into a film in 1963
and then a film again in 1990 and at
this point i don't even know what this
video is going to really be like
it's not a review of the book um is it a
review of both movies
possibly i'm probably going to compare
both the movies and talk about how they
did things similar or different to the
book and
in any case i just want to talk about
lord of the flies there is one of these
movies is superior to
the other and so we'll just talk about
it so lord of the flies is a story that
you might have heard
mentioned as of late um it is about
a group of school boys and they're all
marooned on this island
no adults around which hey great they're
having fun and
in all versions they all find this conch
in the book and the two films the conch
the conscious law
it's the seashell that you essentially
can blow into it it sounds like a horn
and they're like okay
the law is if you're holding the conch
you can talk you have the floor so to
speak
and but you can't talk without the conch
so that's really the first
law that they come up with in order to
have some form of civility and as time
goes on
things start to fall apart and now you
have the lord of the flies references
you have heard
and i've always enjoyed the story of
lord of the flies ever since
at the latest high school but i think
it's because it's the earliest and most
concise
story that makes the point just a very
focused way it shines a spotlight on
human nature it points right to it in
about
300 pages and it's all about that i love
golding's response
the author of the book i love his
response when he talks about
there have been a lot of interpretations
of lord of the flies
but what he intended to put into it is
not as important as what readers got out
of it and so he never really tries to
explain the nuance of what was being
said in certain scenes it's like if you
got that out of it
that's what you got out of it and that's
the important thing i always like that
the 1963 lord of the flies
it's lower budget absolutely and that's
like kind of a burn people have with it
like oh it's super low budget it looks
cheap i don't know i kind of came up in
a time where if you could
make a low budget cheap ass movie that
was kind of cool like look at clerks you
know
it's just like it's clerks but lord of
the flies not really actually i think
clerks is cheaper in both the 1963
version and the 1990 version the acting
isn't
you know it's not top notch in both
cases you're dealing with really young
children who it's not like they have a
lot of acting experience but the weaker
of the two films i'll start with the
weakest one i guess
is the 1990 version the 1990 version is
a textbook case of for the most part
having the point there
and still not making the audience feel
it like with lord of the flies you have
to feel it you
have to feel that these kids are
becoming ravenous
and animalistic you have to feel the
decline of society also they change
things in a weird way
i don't know why i'm just scratching my
head the entire time like you just
burned up screen time concentrating on
this captain who's still alive on the
island which i think was a huge mistake
because
in the 1963 film version and the book in
both cases
the kids just arrive on this island with
no adults that is a
throw them out of the nest and see how
they fly kind of scenario there's no
real hope that an
adult is just going to spring up and be
like all right kids i got you back we're
gonna
i'll lead you but in the 1990 film
version the captain is still alive
though he's kind of in a coma but still
the fact that he is not
dead gives them that hope you can make
the argument that having the captain
alive
on the island but in this comatose state
is
essentially something to give the kids
something to latch onto of the old world
but really that's what
the act of lighting the signal fire to
get rescued
is so it just kind of seemed redundant
but like the captain was a massive waste
of time yeah
later on there's this they believe
there's a monster on the island this
monster
and so one of the kids runs across the
captain who's kind of like in this fever
haze and he thinks he's the monster i
guess i just relate to the parachute and
the book
and the 1963 version because when i was
we're talking pre-kindergarten i was at
this babysitter's house and there was
this parachute in the trees and it was
ripped in a way probably wasn't ripped
like this to be honest with you but
this is how i remember my kid brain
processing it was it was ripped in a way
that it looked like it had two
eyes and a mouth it looked like a big
ghost in the tree
and scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me so
in the story of the book in the 1963
it's like oh we saw a parachute i'm like
i totally understand but from a
filmmaking aspect
some of the acting aside i'll say the
1963 version is the superior version
simply because you start to see the kids
deteriorate
and acting out lashing out there's
scenes where they're just like screaming
at nothing
in that scene where they're all dancing
around the campfire that [ __ ] was
intense i'm not gonna lie
that's what i mean when i say with lord
of the flies you have to feel it the
1963 version made me
feel it more and the fact that lord of
the flies tells the story of human
nature from
children i i think that's brilliant to
be honest with you i always have
as i've aged my perspective as to why
it's kind of
changed or at least evolved like when i
was younger i kind of saw it as
brilliant because
well kids are they're innocent and even
kids are not above human nature but as
i've aged and gotten older i've realized
that
kids are less apt at using masks to
navigate
social situations adults have learned to
do that you look at kids
kids are very emotionally i want to do
this
adults can put on masks and navigate
different social situations you see that
with cafeterias younger
school kids in cafeterias you're like
those are the nerds those are the jocks
those are the goths these are 90s clicks
i'm talking about because
that's when i was at school but in the
workplace you kind of see social
structure but
different people can navigate into
different tables in
a workplace cafeteria in that with kids
not really
being refined and using social masks
as adults do you just you take kids in a
situation like this
and they are human nature incarnate you
know they're the control experiment
they're human nature without any of the
social [ __ ] they're not old enough
to have the experience to have learned
it that's
that's the reason i now see how using
kids and lord of the flies it's actually
a brilliant call but you know a thing i
noticed in this
reading of the book it was like in three
days i
read the book i watched one of the
movies and i watched
the other movie is that it's not just
the absence of civilization it's not
just the lawlessness
it was the great unifier of fear the
fear of this
monster the fear of this thing that was
in the woods
and saw the hunters were like well we
will protect you and at that point
they're like well if we're doing the
work
why aren't we running [ __ ] so it's not
just the absence of law and civilization
it's the absence of law and civilization
mixed with
fear and you take those components and
mix them together it's like the bomb and
die hard with a vengeance you know you
mix them
boom and that is a very important and
timeless lesson
i suppose lord of the flies if you watch
it for the first
time right now you're going to be like
well i've seen these stories before
but again for me it was the earliest and
most concise
telling of this lesson but yeah we've
totally seen
this lesson a lot a lot now you know
movies tv video games he's been in
everything it's kind of the basis of the
walking dead you know oh no civilization
so now people just kind of
act how they act so you have negan the
story of negan it's like they're like
well
lord of the flies but adults even with
the abyss though coffee had you know he
was kind of
deranged because he was down there for
that long and he had that sickness that
they talked about i can't think of the
name of but the abyss is straight up
like i've said before
low-key one of cameron's best movies but
still it's that isolationist feeling of
no law
also paranoia equals bad things
i feel like it all kind of stems from
lord of the flies
but the lessons of lord of the flies are
not to be forgotten in the end
it's the joker's entire philosophy in
the dark night in the dark night when
the joker's talking to batman about
human beings and he's like their morals
their code it's a bad joke dropped at
the first sign of trouble
i'll show you when the chips are down
these civilized people they'll eat each
other
struggling with whether or not that is
accurate is not struggling with whether
or not a mass murdering clown is right
about people it's not even struggling
with whether or not christopher nolan
is right about people it's really
struggling with whether or not
lord of the flies is accurate it's all
lord of the flies philosophy so in the
end i dig
lord of the flies i do feel like it's a
story that lends itself
best to being a book he could probably
do the best job
making it a mini series but the 1963
version is actually remarkably
accurate to the book and it does drag a
bit in the first half of it because this
is kind of what lord of the flies is
it's a slow burn like that but i've
always enjoyed what lord of the flies
has to say about human nature
tribalism fear reacting out of fear and
how
in us it is to go along with the side
that looks like well that's the side of
survival i'm trying to be vague i don't
want to
have any spoilers for the movie from
1963
based off the book written a decade
prior and it's just a lesson that was
relevant
then it was relevant before it was
written is relevant now
will be relevant for centuries to come
if we make it that long alright so lord
of the flies have you read the book have
you seen the movies have you seen a
movie
which one have you seen and which one
did you like or not like hope i covered
it all there i think i did
and what does lord of the flies say to
you how do you process the information
given to you that's important that
that's
very much a part of all of it so
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you